there's this battle now between
faith religion and science and it's not
a real battle
because obviously the only reason
science developed as it did was because
of christianity
that is christianity gave birth to
science the most famous scientists in
history
uh are were christians isaac newton
devout christians spent decades of his
life interpreting scripture
uh george lemaitre the the guy who
discovered the big bang
was a catholic priest father george
lumetra mandel discovered genetics
catholic all these sorts of of people
however there is now in the public view
a debate between religion and science
and
what it really is is a debate between
christianity and encompassed within this
kind of
traditional religion is you know judaism
islam the kind of theistic religions and
science with a capital s and what that
is
is the religion of leftism secular
liberalism which has its own maxims its
own liturgies its own rituals
its own completely irrational beliefs
and nancy pelosi just the other day on
the house floor
described this battle as much as the
left wants to say joe biden's a devout
catholic oh we love religion we support
houses of worship they don't leftism is
a rival religion
and they they look upon people who are
actually
religious christian or otherwise with
total disdain
nancy pelosi explained how in her words
we didn't do it we couldn't pass
legislation until now
because the administration simply
did not believe in testing tracing
treatment wearing masks sanitation
separation and the rest scientific
approach
it has come clear to us now that they
believed in herd immunity
quackery springing right from
the oval office and not denied
sufficiently
by some of the cdc and the rest
so now we have a vaccine and that gives
us hope
a vaccine that is springs from science
people say around here sometimes i'm
faith oriented
so i don't believe in science and i said
well you can do both
science is an answer to our prayers and
our prayers have been answered
with a vaccine and in this legislation
we had provision
for it to be purged developed purchased
and distributed in a way again that is
fair and equitable and free
hold on a minute here i have to question
a few things nancy pelosi said
does anybody really believe that that
someone has come up to nancy pelosi and
said
i'm faith oriented and therefore i don't
believe in science
i don't think i don't think anyone's
ever said that moreover i don't know
that anyone who
who is faith-oriented has ever uttered
the phrase
faith-oriented it's it's like
in that movie the 40 year old virgin you
know steve carell's character is
explaining
what uh what breasts are like but it's
very clear he's never had any encounter
i think that's what it's like with nancy
pelosi and religious people she was yeah
she's like holding it at arm's length
people who are ugh
faith oriented is that is that a word do
you use that in the catechism i don't
know
people who are faith-oriented no that's
not what people say they say i'm
christian i'm jewish a muslim
they don't say or they say i'm leftist
i'm liberal
they don't say faith oriented and nobody
has said i'm religious therefore i don't
believe in science
what they'll say is i'm a christian and
therefore i'm morally opposed to
uh taking a vaccine that was developed
using stem cells from
aborted babies well you don't believe in
science no i believe in science
uh i believe that was a baby right i
i'm following the scientific method i'm
inquiring as to what this physical
object how it came to be it came to be
through aborted babies
and there's something beyond the
physical it's called the metaphysical
and
there's a moral order and there i have
moral obligations and we're not just
meat puppets we're also we also are
souls and i just think it's wrong to do
that and so i'm not going to do it and i
also
believe in science because i think
there's a 99.7 chance i'll survive this
virus
and i also believe in science and i know
that there is such a thing as herd
immunity despite what nancy pelosi is
saying she's calling her immunity
quackery
herd immunity has been a medical concept
for ages and ages
a well accepted medical concept it's
still it's still described on the world
health organization website even though
they keep trying to redefine it
according to the new politically correct
standards
if you're faith-oriented it's like do
you remember when hillary clinton
described there was a massacre of
christians on easter
and she didn't refer to the christians
she referred to the easter worshipers
this is a woman who has never thought
seriously about christianity ever once
in her life
she's probably thought seriously about
some leftist ideology masquerading as
christianity but no no christian refers
to
easter worshipers